est ce que vous pensez qu'on aurait pu
éviter ce drame
eric naulleau
je réponds oui je réponds même deux fois
oui je réponds oui
quant aux circonstances précises de de
l'assassinât le terroriste avait déjà
posté une photographie de décapitation
certains de ces postes avaient été
signalés sur la plateforme pharos
ensuite will samuel patty a été victime
d'une campagne de harcèlement numérique
donc c'est encore montée d'un cran et
finalement on a vu que le parent d'élève
qui d'ailleurs s'appuyer sur des faits
complètement fallacieux complètement
faux s'est fait accompagner pour
rencontrer la proviseure par un
islamiste endurcis donc à partir de là
je dirais que tous les voyants étaient
au rouge ça c'est pour l'attentât
proprement dit mais c'est quelque chose
qui vient de beaucoup plus loin
c'est quelque chose qui vient de moi je
situe sa en 1989 quand il ya eu cet
incident avec les collégiennes voilait
de creil
ça avait défrayé la chronique c'était
devenu un sujet national et c'est à
partir de ce moment là que la république
a commencé à parlementer avec le
communautarisme à godiller avec
l'islamisme a essayé de te trouver un
moyen terme
au lieu d'appliquer la laïcité à la
française qui est très claire et
malheureusement on a payé ses 30 ans de
renoncement on a payé ses 30 ans de
recul
moi je trouve absolument incroyable que
quelqu'un qui est fiché s et qui est
reconnu comme islamistes endurcis
puissent pénétrer dans une école
publique pour parlementer avec un père
d'élève et la proviseure c'est pour dire
à quel point de capitulation on en est
arrivé tout ça a été préparé par ces
renoncements tout ça a été préparé par
un certain discours alors là ça va
hurler parce que l'adjectif en ce moment
c ur les islamo gauchistes c'est à dire
avec une partie de la gauche qui a
décidé de pactiser avec l'islamisme pour
des raisons d'égarement idéologique
pensez à qui je pense à la france un
soumises en premier en premier lieu mais
pas seulement mais pas seulement qui a
décidé pour des raisons électorales pour
des raisons d'égarement idéologique par
bêtise tout simplement
et malheureusement et bien
le meurtre de samuel hépatique
j'aimerais dire que c'est pour solde de
tout compte mais je pense qu'il y aura
encore d'autres drames je pense qu'il y
aura d'autres attentats parce que ça va
être très très dur de revenir en arrière
d'autant que comme karim l'a souligné
malheureusement là le débat national est
un peu parti dans tous les sens et une
extrême confusion mais je réponds deux
fois oui parce que cet homme était
repéré et parce que des tas de gens ont
préparé pendant 30 ans n'ont pas
l'assassinât lui même évidemment mais le
terrain idéologique sur lequel est né
cet attentat raquel garrido
moi j'ai envie de garder un peu de
dignité de gravité j'ai pas aimé la
façon dont dans karim et fatiha où on
changeait tout à l'heure je pense qu'il
faut savoir raison garder et rester
conscient de la vraie situation je
remercie vous remercie infiniment
sofiane et julie de venir témoigner
parce que ça le plus important il ya un
homme qui est mort et c'est bizzbee
l'adulte et ses guéguerres parfois un
peu politicienne et un peu surjouée je
pense que doit peut-être vous choquer
mais en tout cas moi je suis touché de
voir que vous avez visiblement bien
compris ce que voulez vous dire votre
enseignant et notamment julie quand tu
dis que que la liberté de conscience la
liberté de pensée elle est totale mais
que la liberté de s'exprimer
elle peut être régi par la loi ça par
exemple cet été les notions font pas
facile à appréhender qui sont très
importants et en france c'est vrai que
on discute de savoir quelle est la
portée de notre liberté de s'exprimer à
propos de la religion et j'ai beaucoup
aimé le texte de sarah forestier mais
elle se trompe sur une expression c'est
l'expression droit au blasphème
c'est en fait cette expression bar
donnez moi la figure politique c'est une
oxymore
il ne peut pas en fait le blasphème
n'existe que dans le monde des croyants
et dans le monde des croyants il ya
évidemment pas le cas au baptême mais
dans le monde
séculaire c'est à dire celui qui nous
concerne tous et dans lequel on laisse
pas rentrer la religion le blasphème
n'existe pas alors pourquoi avec des
gens qui pensent à la barre dont eric
naulleau jamais la question est déjà la
question pardonne moi je parle aux
jeunes par des notions que je posais la
question d'erick eux
je termine sur ce point là il n'y a pas
de droit au blasphème
parce que le blasphème n'existe pas dans
le droit français on note puisque nous
séparons voilà le priver du commun et
nous n'acceptons pas en france de
limitation à notre liberté d'expression
à cause du regard des croyants le regard
des croyants ne peut pas imposer sa loi
dans notre sphère commune légale
voilà donc arrêtons de parler de droit
au blasphème il n'y a pas de droit au
blasphème
voilà j'ai fait ça augmente alors que je
pense que de l'avoir fait parce que je
pense que c'est aussi sans doute
peut-être ce que c'est mais elle pâtit
essayer de faire comprendre les quais
très difficile et il ya plein de profs
qui essaye de faire comprendre ça c'est
pas simple parce que les politiques font
le contraire
les politiques font du client tourisme
font du communautarisme faisant la
promotion c'est inouï quand même
franchement alors oui dans quelle
pourquoi c'est dur à prendre parce que
vous introduisez la confusion c'est vous
qui introduisent et la confusion
ils écouteront également avec des
islamistes lannan en sens inverse et
sont absolument en désaccord avec toutes
les valeurs de laïcité et de la
république
alors oui j'aime bien peu bizarre de
voir un parti légal s'acoquine est avalé
le nounours moi je suis une militante
conclut il vient de très bien fait très
longue date et je suis et j'ai toujours
été ici à sur ce plateau depuis toujours
une quelqu'un qui a essayé d'être
pédagogique sur ce que c'est la laïcité
j'ai toujours défendu la laïcité la
laïcité en france elle est remise en
cause d'abord et avant tout par des
mairies clientéliste parce que pour
faire du communautarisme
il faut du clientélisme c'est les deux
faces d'une même monnaie et vous avez
des mères qui vont s qualité dans des
cérémonies religieuses
vous avez des mères qui achètent des
voix à tel ou tel groupement de telle ou
telle culture ou qu'elle telle ou telle
religion d'accord et là dessus la france
soumise ne peut pas être taxé
aujourd'hui à bien la chaussée du mois
manquait jamais être vraiment chez les
rovers
jean luc mélenchon c'est du marché ce
groupe - certes je ne comprends pas mais
ça veut dire quoi en matière il n'ya pas
de mer de la france a soumis ce taux qui
s'adresse au niveau national
il s'adresse vraiment c'est le marché de
rungis du clientélisme la dira t-il
kouassi a déjà les chaînes parce qu'il
ya des fois réservé aux enfants
il défend léger dès le début
obernai silice qui a osé d'hernani
excusez-moi mois les noms toute façon
j'ai encore du mal mais vous avez raison
de me reprendre
qui dit que les mécréants il a réutilisé
ce moulin dans un discours mécréants
c'est comme dropt blasphème
il se place dans une grille complètement
religieuse quand j'ai enchaîné avec il
ya le rêve raconte que l'état que le
président macron cible les musulmans
qu'on traque les musulmans qu'on fait du
mal aux musulmans mais à votre avis
qu'en pensez-vous de la crise et posez
vous la question de qui reçoit ce
discours et qu'est-ce que ça produit
comme effet donc on peut pas parler que
des maires qui utilise un vous avez
raison à mais il ya aussi des mercis
aussi donné d'oise est en tout cas bien
réussi un tribut de dandé mayo près sur
l'europe